merci beaucoup à vous tous bonjour aux
jeunes républicains présents aujourd'hui
bonjour a vous tous je vais vous dire
simplement quelques mots pour vous
remercier de votre présence remercier
daniel fasquelle de nos accueillir
aujourd'hui dans cette très belle ville
il y a un an quasiment jour pour jour on
organisait à nice un campus
alors bon il faisait un petit peu plus
chaud et c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle je parle un peu du nez donc je
vous prie de m'excuser pour ça et il ya
un an donc comme je vous le disais on se
réunissait avec beaucoup de jeunes
républicains de france pour deux raisons
particulières
la première raison par la première
raison c'était que l'on souhaitait tous
le retour de nicolas sarkozy et un an
après c'est chose faite et un an après
nous sommes très très heureux
aujourd'hui de pouvoir travailler tous
ensemble à ses côtés la deuxième raison
est qu'ils n'étaient pas des moindres
c'est qu'il fallait absolument relancer
la machine des jeunes républicains à
l'époque des jeunes populaires et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on y est arrivé et
c'est en partie grâce au travail de
stéphane tiki il n'est pas encore arrivé
mais s'il vous plaît si vous pouvez
l'applaudir parce que vraiment il a fait
un travail fantastique pendant ces six
derniers mois
alors voilà comme je vous le disais de
raison particulière le retour de nicolas
sarkozy et relancer la machine des
jeunes républicains alors on commence à
le faire stéphane l'a fait évidemment il
nous reste encore beaucoup de boulot et
c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi vous
êtes présents pour ce week end
c'est justement pour pouvoir débattre
pour pouvoir proposer et c'est la raison
aussi de l'importance de notre mouvement
il faut impérativement que la jeunesse
reprenne sa place au coeur de notre
famille politique
et vous allez le faire tout à l'heure
simon et antoine vous ont présenté le
programme
pendant deux jours il va falloir
travailler proposer et faire en sorte
que les jeunes républicains et deux
nouveaux une voix forte dans notre
famille politique
alors voilà plus que jamais les
républicains ont besoin de vous
travaillez exprimez vous et au cours de
ce week end vous aurez l'occasion aussi
de rencontrer vos élus d'assister à la
plénière est vraiment gentil cela su
exprimer vous ce moment c'est le vôtre
alors en avant pour travailler tous
ensemble pour un nouveau souffle
populaire pour les jeunes républicains
merci beaucoup